.
>>> Tonight exodus at last, some
70,000 people who have been
stuck at burning man are now
slowly being allowed to leave.
You are looking here at live
pictures of this massive caravan
of festival Goers making their
way out of the desert.
Rain turned the normally dry
Nevada lake bed where the
festival is held into a sticky, muddy mess shutting down the
only road in or out, stranding
people for days.
Nick watt is out front.
>> Reporter: The exodus
underway, that sunshine you see
is the savior drying the mud
just enough for tires to grip,
not sink into sludge.
>> It was impossible to
function, impossible to move
around, a lot of struggling
people in what became very cold,
very storm-like conditions.
People's tents and the entire
camps became pretty much
destroyed.
>> Reporter: More than 70,000
people were basically trapped
for days.
Trapped in this makeshift desert
city that pops up in Nevada
every year around labor day
filled with campers and kroet
creators, fun lovers and those
with their freak flag flying,
that culminates in the man
burning.
>> We planned on leaving right
after the man burned, which is
Saturday night, and then it
started raining on us.
Everybody took their shoes off,
started dancing in the mud.
It was great, and then the
reality sunk in that we couldn't
leave.
>> Reporter: Chris rock and some
other celebs decided to take the
only uncomfortable exit
available.
>> We just got up and started
walking, and we walked about
three hours in the mud, and he
was happy.
It was me, I think Cindy
Crawford walked with us, Kaia
Gerber, Austin butler, it was a
challenge, but it was honestly
one of the highlights of the
whole trip.
>> Reporter: Many embracing the
ethos of self-reliance.
>> I was waiting for the
looting, honestly.
It's really beautiful actually
when you go into the camps,
everybody was helping each other
out.
>> Burning man, raining man,
suck it up.
Stick it out.
>> I had my rv here and all my
other camp mates have rvs or big
rental trucks or things like
that, and getting those out was
basically impossible.
Sure, you could have walked out.
What am I going tad with all my
stuff.
>> Reporter: All this Chao
caused by less than an inch of
rain.
>> Even just the slightest bit
of rain makes everything super
slick.
You have like five pounds of mud
on your feet.
>> This is a desert, nothing
much grows, she soil isn't
lovely and absorbent, it's just
miles of gray clay.
Most years this is a dusty, not
a muddy mess.
And under an inch of rain, well,
that's still two or three
months' worth of rain in this
arid land within just 24 hours.
Tonight they will finally burn
the man for those that remain
and pray for no rain.
So at noon today, organizers
said there were still about
64,000 people on the site.
Two hours later they officially
opened the road.
But they are advising people
maybe you want to wait until
tomorrow, but by the look of
those lines, not many people are
taking that advice.
Listen, radical self-reliance,
that's what they say is one of
the central ethos of this
festival, this year proved why.
Briana.
>> Sure did, Nick watt, thank
you.
>> And out front now is caz who
is still at burning man.
We are looking.
We have some video, actually,
that you sent us of just some
incredibly thick mud and soaking
wet tents.
What has it been like for you
all living in these conditions?
>> Actually, you know, we have a
really well-organized camp, camp
daydream, and half the camp is
rvs, and half the camp is tents,
so as soon as the tents started
getting water logged or
unlivable, people in rvs started
taking in some of the tenters so
everybody was warm.
We also have shipping
containers, semitrucks that we
had emptied out and we made
really beautiful lounges in
there for people to sleep in,
blankets, you know, we are a
community that comes together in
hard times, so this actually
could end up being one of the
best burning mans for a lot of
people because it used all of
the principles all at once, and
tested it for the full
experience.
>> Yeah, it certainly did test
you all, and you know, with that
idea of self-reliance here, that
is also something that was
tested.
But that said, do you think that
there are things that could have
been handled better by
organizers?
What are your thoughts on that?
>> Actually, so this is the
first time this has been, you
know, in 35 years that they've
been doing this festival, I
think this is the first time
that anything like this has
happened.
I think they handled it to the
best of their ability and put
out all the proper instructions,
which is not to move.
Then it was up to the attendees
to follow those rules.
As soon as you start moving
30,000 pound vehicles, rvs,
things without 4 by 4, you're
going to get stuck, so if you
listen to the rules, it's all
drying up right now.
People are starting to leave,
but the people that started to
leave and panic or wanted to get
out ahead of time while it was
still raining, they're still
stuck out there.
They're still stuck out on the
road out, and they're causing a
bottleneck situation for all of
the people that actually stayed
and listened.
>> So you've stayed, you've
listened.
When are you planning to leave?
>> I'm listening.
I'm probably going to leave
after the man burns tonight or
tomorrow morning because as you
guys said, and we've been
notified that the Gates are now
open.
The problem is that this Monday
is the mass exodus, so this is
when the traffic will be the
heaviest, so people can plan on
sitting in their cars from
anywhere from two to 12 to 14
hours on the way out so I'm
going to wait and hopefully just
be this line for a couple hours
before I head to Reno.
>> Patience is a virtue for
sure, caz, thank you so much for
being with us, and we hope that
you have a wonderful time.
You're a very optimistic, even
under these conditions.
>> It's such a great community
to be a part of, and it really